hello gamers and welcome to another
episode of blood line where we examine
what if anything makes a movie scary I'm
Jade a rich and I'm Jordan Russia Ola
and this week we are talking about
Silent Hill revelation which is based on
the third game in the Silent Hill series
and it is the story of Sharon AKA
Heather and her father they're on the
run for theoretically a murder that her
father committed a few states back when
really they're actually on the run from
the fiery hell scape that is silent hill
trying to pull Heather back into its
clutches because she's very important to
the cause of their existence let me stop
you there and ask you Jordan do you play
video games not since like mario kart 64
not since 1982 Atari console so I don't
know if we're qualified to review this
movie yeah but we're going to anyway
because that has never stopped us in the
past no let's just go for it
video game horror that's we're dealing
with this week and here are the criteria
that we have established what make that
kind of movie the first and foremost is
an immersive world you need to have a
universe that gamers can recognize and
feel like has been faithful to what
they're following and that also non
gamers can attach to you and feel like
is a really convincing space and I think
that they did a really good job that in
this movie the art direction was really
consistent really beautiful really well
done the creature effects were great
movement the choreography just all of it
looked really really beautiful and I
think it kind of maybe they spent too
much time on how it looked at the out of
time on how it played with character
development and plot yeah it was like
they took a pass on the fact that they I
think they knew it looked really good
and I think that they knew they had a
good foundation to go off of from the
game because the first movie was creepy
they built up tension really well in the
first one there was better character
development if you have stars like Sean
Bean down carrie-anne moss and Kit
Harington you would expect this movie to
be good but they were just like phoning
it in in the sanctuary beneath the
amusement park so number two is rules
and limitations of that world yes kind
of like sci-fi like our colleague Adam
Roger says in sci-fi you have to set the
rules and set the limitations and stick
to those rules and limitations because
if you don't the world kind of falls
apart okay and in this they kept
interjecting the rules now you gotta go
all i hears them Adan you got to find
the other medallion you got to go to
this level you got to go to that love
you gotta and with this pacing was so
annoying after a while it was like scare
explanation scare explanation it's like
going to a friend's house and watching
them play a video game or like dude you
invited me over not to watch you play
video games but the chill out two goes
and okay well that I agree with you and
third criteria a formidable hero or
heroine who you want to pull for who's
either gonna be smart enough to solve
the puzzle or strong enough to kick some
ass she was neither she was so passive
she kind of let things happen to her
yeah oh here's a mannequin arachnoid
chasing me and now I guess I hey what's
up where's my dad and then we
my dad weird like connection with her
dad like sitting on his lap like that
like girl you are too old to sit in your
dad's well that was like profile turn at
the waist grabbed the wrong kind of
movie yeah I took a turn well number one
when you transfer to a new school don't
alienate everybody by being rude and
sullen yeah try to make a few friends
friends that might notice when you go
missing number to stop doing meth if
you're having waking hallucinations
where your high school main hallway
turns into a red burning like pit of
despair and there's a creature coming at
you and then you snap out of it you
think it's like normal and not something
you should talk to anybody about then
you should probably seek treatment
invest in a 99-cent GPS app on your
phone that way you won't take a wrong
turn into hell yeah number four don't go
to Silent Hill if your dad's telling you
not to go if your nightmares are the
only thing telling you to go if anybody
on the street would basically tell you
not to go don't go to Silent Hill we're
telling you don't know go to zachs
inhale hours of sleep lost I shudder to
ask je ne uh I think I actually nodded
off in the movie theater so I gained a
few hours of sleep what about you I'm
gonna say about an hour cuz that's the
amount of time it took me to drive as a
theater and back and like park and stuff
all right video pic of the week based on
these genre we just discussed I'm gonna
go with resident evil the first one only
because melee ova vich is pretty one
hundred percent agree and I'm gonna say
if you want to go see a movie based on a
video game go see wreck-it Ralph
Disney's wonderful tale of video game
characters coming together because the
horror video game movie genre is pretty
sparsely populated and even more
sparsely populated with movies I want
you to go see ya so go see wreck-it
Ralph yeah all is not lost Silent Hill
revelation is not a wasted experience
there were definitely some artistic
highlights that would be worth seeing on
the big screen if you were a fan of the
game the creepy nurses that like could
only move when you were moving so you
kind of had to stay still but you had to
get try to get away from them that was a
nice little catch their eye with Jen
scary scene and a lot of the creatures
were practically based it wasn't like
entirely CGI computer-generated so you
could see some really interesting human
movements and in a way that if I was in
front of that it was it was happening to
me that was coming at me they're really
scary yeah yeah anyway that's it for
this episode of bloodline email us at
bloodline at wired.com let us know what
you think give us some recommendations
for movies you would like us to see yeah
and in the meantime we will be back next
week with another great selection but
remember until then if it's just a movie